[Music]
larson i need you to come over to my
house and hook up with me every day
after school
what
yeah you me sex stuff
how about a little back story while i
was setting the academic bar for our
generation my classmates were more
concerned with other things angry i'm
dtf
oh [ __ ]
we both know you don't do things you're
not great at god i can't be bad at this
this is not the time to be a
perfectionist i'm gonna blow
you blow whatever you're comfortable
with
to master sexual excellence i'm going to
create an app that would collect data
and prescribe steps for a successful
sexual experience i should be collecting
data from my fellow students
there are certain partnered pleasure
approaches the rock and roll the surfs
up the double action revolver the spock
the reverse spot damn if you want to be
a dick-sucking artist a penis picaxo a
bonnet afrida [ __ ]
glow it's all about the tip
have you selected a practice partner yet
i can't sexualize you i respect you too
much for your brain for your
independence my god
i can't believe you just did that it's
fair play
technically it's foreplay don't be mad
at the confidence here we go god's
speech
i think we can call today's experiment a
success
i have a hypothesis love leads to sex
and sex leads to love our dynamic needs
to remain strictly professional for the
sake of the experiment so if we're not
doing your experiment we can't hang
you kids are overly worried about
getting good at the sex stuff it's a
relationship that takes practice
stay safe
larson are we ready oh yeah
it's happening
you just launched a harpoon without
tying the rope off i'll tie it off i i
have several ropes ribbed ropes
pre-lubed ropes reel it in skipper
you got to try things to know what you
want there's a diversity of options
you've got your lefties your righties
your straight shooters your curvatures
cool i'll just be at hometown buffet
sampling the local beef
you